[Музика]
Привіт усім, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звуть Наталія Ешкомб, давайте
почнемо, тому сьогодні, як ви бачите, я
буду не лише вчителем, але я також буду
лікарем, тому давайте переглянемо  різні
симптоми і прописую різні рецепти
[Музика]
давайте почнемо з першого, тому я
чекаю, поки прийде мій пацієнт, привіт,
привіт, як справи сьогодні я думаю, що все добре,
так як тебе звати мене звати  Біллі
Біллі Айліш о, дуже дякую, мене
звати Наталія,
тому скажіть мені, Біллі, які проблеми,
лікарю, я проводив багато часу за
телефоном, тому що у мене є обліковий запис Instagram, у
мене є Facebook,
я спілкуюся з друзями, я перевірив
домашнє завдання і я  люблю створювати відео
на телефоні, і я помітив, що мій
зір не такий хороший, як був раніше,
тому давайте перевіримо твій зір, давайте, так
чи бачите ви літери так, я б хотів
, щоб ви прочитали літери, але перед цим
почнемо з  ліве око, тож, будь ласка,
закрийте праве око  Чи можу я зробити це своїм
телефоном, не користуйся рукою, будь ласка, добре,
так що закрийте праве око і давайте читати D
it's eedf CZPE добре, зараз закрийте
ліве око і полікуйте правим,
давайте edckf
і ще раз я не  впевнений, що
це K чи e, це добре,
дякую, Біллі, так виглядає, що твій
зір майже в порядку, але у тебе
є проблеми зі світлом, дозволь мені дати тобі кілька
очних крапель, добре, скажи, як ти пишеш твоє
ім’я, і це Біллі Б i подвійний, тобто
добре, а прізвище це ірландське, його
EILI Sh
фантастично, тому я даю тобі очні краплі,
і як часто я буду капати їх собі в
очі раз на день, це твій очні
краплі і твій рецепт,
дуже дякую, я можу піти
зараз  поки немає, будь ласка, спробуйте обмежити використання
свого телефону та різних пристроїв, тому що
це дуже впливає на ваш зір добре
так, тому побачимось через тиждень
до побачення
[Музика]
наступне, будь ласка, привіт, привіт, як вас звати,
зробіть стрибок  фантастично, так які
проблеми з нею О д  octor У мене болить зуб,
це справді болить
добре, тому у мене є питання, як часто
ви їсте солодощі, о, мушу зізнатися,
я люблю солодощі,
я люблю їсти шоколад, цукор і
всі солодкі газовані напої.
я кожен день багато цукру,
і ти чистиш зуби
двічі на день о, я повинен тобі сказати, що я
роблю це тільки ввечері, це не дуже
добре, краще вживати його двічі на день
вранці та ввечері як
щодо  перекус, коли вам потрібно щоразу
полоскати рот, чи можна
це зробити о, чи можу я зробити це з водою,
достатньо води, о, дуже дякую, тож давайте
запишемося на прийом до стоматолога, чи
буде боляче, це добре, ми збираємося використати
анестетики без болю о, дякую, як
тебе знову звати дула і моє прізвище
Лі Бай Лі па фантастично, так що щодо
вівторка 9:00 я боюся, що я зайнятий, чи
може це бути 10:00, будь ласка, можливо середа
о так середа  Я вільний цілий
день, тому середа 10:00 будь-коли,
наскільки сильний твій біль  тепер тобі
потрібні знеболюючі, хм, це я, дум, я думаю,
що можу затриматися заздалегідь, я
дам тобі знеболююче, якщо біль
стане сильнішим, будь ласка, прийми одну таблетку
добре, дякую
, це твоя таблетка і твій
рецепт, дякую, у тебе є  чудовий день,
дякую, побачимось у середу о
10 ранку так, до побачення,
[Музика]
далі будь ласка, привіт, привіт, як тебе звати
Анджеліна Джолі, як ти, Анджеліна добре,
лікар не дуже добре я бачу, так
які  проблеми чи можете ви їх описати
так я погано сплю у мене безсоння я
втратив апетит я втратив вагу я відчуваю
занепокоєння іноді моє серце б'ється занадто
швидко і так я просто не почуваюся добре,
здається, давайте почнемо з
тесту  зауважте,
ні, все добре, добре, дозвольте мені перевірити ваш
артеріальний тиск,
мені потрібна ваша рука так, звичайно,
зараз буде боліти, це не просто розслабтеся,
покладіть руку так, давайте, так що це 170,
добре, це трохи низько, тож як щодо вашого
звичайного артеріального тиску?  в нормі
воно вище t  його
я бачу, ймовірно, це наслідки твого
безсоння та інших симптомів добре, дозволь мені
перевірити ваш пульс, будь ласка, добре, готовий,
це 65, добре,
зараз, чи не могли б ви, будь ласка, встаньте
і присядьте, давайте з десятьма,
давайте спробуємо ще раз
так добре, схоже, що це  110 це
трохи високо, тому вам потрібно добре спати,
будь ласка, дотримуйтесь гігієни сну,
пам’ятайте про правила вимикайте
світло, не використовуйте ноутбук та інші
електронні пристрої, будь ласка, закрийте
штори, ви можете використовувати розслаблюючу музику,
яка допоможе вам добре спати  дякую,
і було оголошено, що з моєю дієтою, тому,
будь ласка, використовуйте більше овочів, менше
цукру і пийте трохи води, скільки
ви випиваєте в день, я думаю, що дві
склянки води в день, це точно недостатньо,
будь ласка, скористайтеся півтора літрами
принаймні добре, так як тебе знову звати
Анджеліна Джолі,
це Джо як я ІІ я бачу, я даю тобі кілька
вітамінів, щоб почувати себе краще о, дякую,
і як часто я буду приймати їх двічі
на день один вранці та
один ввечері  дякую, і це
на тиждень, і я хотів би побачити вас
через тиждень
добре, ми домовимося про зустріч
на наступний тиждень, будь ласка, звичайно, це
той самий час, ви знаєте, чи можу я отримати
його раніше вранці, будь ласка, добре,
дев'ята  я так, дякую, фантастично, тому до зустрічі
та 9:00 ранку, дякую, це твій
рецепт дякую, ваші вітаміни,
дякую, гарного дня і побачимо через
тиждень дуже дякую, доктор, до побачення
[Музика]
далі будь ласка
привіт привіт як вас звати ой давай МА
я бачу Ольга що з твоєю рукою
ну лікаре я грав у
хованки зі своїми дітьми і
впав і ну у мене болить вся рука я
бачу добре я  боюся, що він може зламатися,
нам обов’язково потрібен рентген, тому я
призначив вам рентген, добре, дякую,
і коли я можу його отримати, ви можете отримати його в
будь-який час, просто підіть до кімнати два два сім
і з’явиться світловий сигнал, коли
лікар готовий, медсестра зателефонує для вас ах
дуже дякую, я маю платити чи
це бухта  червоний моєю страховкою це
покриває ваша страховка не турбуйтеся
про це дякую дуже бережіть,
будь ласка, дякую до побачення
[Музика]
далі будь ласка, привіт, привіт, як справи
сьогодні я не дуже добре, лікарю  подивіться,
як вас звуть
Майлі Сайрус, як це пишеться, це штучний
інтелект Лі і це Сайрус, ми в
порядку, то які проблеми, Майлі,
лікарю, у мене болить горло, і я думаю,
що у мене це вже п'ять днів, я
бачу  чи є у вас якісь інші симптоми
нежить немає кашлю ні, а як щодо температури
я не впевнений, що я не перевірив свою
температуру, давайте зробимо це зараз,
так що це термометр, будь ласка, покладіть його
під руку, добре, дайте мені побачити ммм, це
Satta 7  тож схоже, що це може бути
застуда, але вона може стати сильніше,
тому давайте почнемо з кількох таблеток Сьюзен,
це допоможе вам з болем у горлі,
і якщо у вас виникнуть інші проблеми,
будь ласка, негайно зателефонуйте мені, дякую,
скільки я прийму на день  від трьох
до п'яти - це нормально, тільки ефект
буде заспокоєним  це допоможе вам
розмовляти, їсти та пити
багато теплого чаю та інших напоїв, будь ласка
, не пийте холодну воду та газовані напої,
дякую, ми домовимося про іншу
зустріч, якщо у вас виникнуть
проблеми, негайно передзвоніть мені  якщо не буде
проблем, я побачу вас через тиждень
дякую добре дякую дуже до побачення
[Музика]
добре, тому, як ви бачите сьогодні, ми
відвідали багато різних лікарів, і ваше
домашнє завдання буде  створіть
власне діалогове вікно, відвідавши одного лікаря, ви можете
зняти його та завантажити у свій
обліковий запис у соцмережах або надіслати на мою електронну пошту, тепер
ви можете побачити його на екрані, і наступного
разу ми почнемо з одного
з діалогів, тож вам приємно  день і
до наступного разу, до побачення
[Музика].